(upbeat music)
- We're here with
James Davis and this is
- [Group] Celebrity
Fashion Surgery
- Hello
- Hey guys
- This is like a wound and not
really like an ICU situation
- What would you do?
- Well I mean I'm
loving this camo,
there's so much I love
about this street style.
But the gray shoes James,
you didn't have better
sneakers to wear?
- Ah, these shoes are
like the top Jordans
that came out this year.
- They might be Jordans,
but they're gray.
- Is it a gray overkill?
- I would give yourself
a pop of color on that.
- Always wear one item
to plug your show.
- And what's that TV show?
- Hood Adjacent
with James Davis.
- Bling around your
neck, bling on your ears,
where's the bling
on your fingers?
- I haven't met that
special someone.
- Are you looking?
- Are you looking, James?
- I mean I was looking,
but I'm not looking to like
focus on like one
thing at this juncture
in my journey romantically.
- It's okay, I'll do
an open relationship.
- Fern, relax.
- I'm sorry.
- I think it's only fair that
we've critiqued your outfit,
why don't you give us a go?
- I love magenta.
You look like lipstick
wrapped in saran wrap.
- I'll take that
as a compliment.
- Oh your shoes are
fresh, what size are you?
- I'm a size 10 James.
- In the 'hood when anyone
asks what your size is,
you say my size.
'Cause if your size was my
size, I might want to take 'em.
So I'm gonna do this again.
What size are your shoes?
- They're my size James.
- Oh respect, well
you can have 'em.
- I would drop the bottom of
his jacket a little bit lower.
It's almost crop toppish right
here, it stops very suddenly.
Everything else is great.
You're like an A-, a 92%.
- And I'm at 971
(bleep)
that was my phone number.
- And I'm at 2
(bleep)
- Enough of that,
that's enough of that.
I've never been given an
A- before, in my life.
So I would like to say, what
is your shoe size James?
- (laughs loudly) my size homie.
(upbeat music)